What what was it specifically when you
read the Quran? What was it that clicked
for you and said, "Yeah, this this
couldn't have been from man. This this
is from God." The fact that it was from
beginning to end because you have to
read it from the beginning to end. So,
you cannot you cannot just go from
around, you know, you'll be confused,
lost. If you read it from beginning to
end, you will realize that it's it stays
consistent
from beginning to end. Like it's it's so
full of different topics
linked together in a very consistent,
coherent way, you know what I mean? Do
you have a
Do you have a Do you have an example
because Karim, I I've read the Quran and
I I actually see the opposite. I see
that the Quran is very discombobulated
with its topics. Like it'll you'll have
five verses talking about one thing and
then the next verse will be talking
about something completely different
that is disconnected, that has nothing
to do with what was said previously. So,
I mean No, when I say say consistent,
I I Like I told you, it's about
different topics, you know what I mean?
It cannot just be So, are you saying
that if a book is consistent then like
with its topic and what it talks about,
then that means it's from God? No, no,
no, I'm I'm coming to the the the the
I get it. It's not It doesn't seem like
it's Yeah, from God or anything. It
seems like anyone can do it. This is
what I need, Karim. I I I need I need
what is it like like what is the the
thing that makes it clear that it's from
God? Like that's what
>> Yeah, I'm coming I'm coming to the I'm
coming to the. So, when you see this in
the beginning it's it's superficially it
it seems like it's normal, yeah, it's
consistent, topics different and that's
it. But when you see the history of it,
when was this book written? Do you agree
like do we agree both now that Do you
know that the Quran was written we
more than 1,400
1 more than 1,400 years ago, right? We
have
>> [clears throat]
>> that's undeniable. We cannot deny that,
right? Correct. It comes from 1,400
years
>> We have copies. We have I researched it.
We found proofs that it goes back to the
source like when it was first revealed.
We No,
we don't have that. We we do know that
it's 1,400 years ago, but it doesn't go
back to like a source.
>> I don't want I don't have the real
source here, but one was the Do you know
when was the the latest the oldest copy
of the Quran or the You know what I
mean? When when does it go
>> So we we we have we have like like
manuscripts or that that are pretty old,
but the problem is is that a lot of them
have variations with the Qurans that we
have out today. So the like the main
Yeah, there's there's variations in the
readings in the text that don't match
other manuscripts that we have today.
But when I did my research it was like
114 chapter
uh same number of verses, same number of
No, you don't you don't have a
By the way, you don't have you don't
have a Quran. We don't have a like a
full 114 chapters Quran that dates back
1,400 years ago. We don't we don't have
that. Like around the world right now
like any place anywhere in the world
right now or even in the past like we
can go like 500 years ago, 300 years
ago, 200 years ago, all the copies we
have, do we agree that they're all the
same? No, bro. I No difference No
difference in chapters nor in verses nor
in words. Yeah, there's I have three
different Qurans here. They're they're
different. Now, they have the same
number of chapters, but they
>> Verses, words, and everything? They have
their their difference in wording. Yeah,
they they read different. No, no. Words,
words, number of words, verses, and
everything. Yeah, the word the wording
is different. What do you mean wording
is different? I don't know. I'll show
you an example. So So this Quran right
here, this is called the the Qaloon
Quran, right? Qaloon. Recitation of
Qaloon.
This one
is the Warsh Warsh recitation
>> Warsh Warsh I got it.
And this one is Hafs. Okay? Yeah.
>> So I'm going to show you on the screen
um cuz it's it's just easier to show
you. There's a
a Muslim website. It's a really good
website actually. It has a data whole
database of Quran readings and
recitations and stuff like that. I'm
going to show you that there there's
some that have you know words missing or
were there or their words are different
with different meanings. Let me just
show you that really quick, okay? On my
screen. So, this is chapter 57 verse 24.
This will be the Hafs reading, okay?
Yeah. This is the Hafs the first one
that we're reading.
So, do you read Arabic by the way? Yes,
yes, I read Arabic. Oh, perfect. Okay,
that's good. So,
you see you see the word here huwa,
right? Yes.
All right. So, the word huwa there and
then it finishes out the verse. Allah
huwa I don't know that word. You would
know. I know it.
Mhm.
Okay. So,
this word huwa when we go to the Qalun
reading, it's gone. It's not there.
And when we look at the Warsh reading,
it's also not there.
Okay?
So,
it's a word difference.
That's the difference you were said you
were talking about? It's one of them.
Yes, it's one of them. And that's is
like
um
that is that is for you enough to say,
"Yes, the Quran is changed. It's
different from this from Is enough for
you to say, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah,
it's it's enough to say that they are
not word for word the same. We know We
know that they're But you realize like
I'm sorry. But you realize that me as a
Arabic speaking
person, a Muslim, you know, when I see
this like you're not giving me some like
some
some like breaking argument of what of
what of saying that it's changed, you
know? It's the same literally the same,
you know? It reads the same except
>> How does it read the same?
How does it read the same if a word is
there in one verse and not in
>> the
>> Allow me to If I read it right now to me
for the in the first one
will Hamid. I go to the second one in
Allah will Hamid. It literally is the
same meaning. It literally there's
nothing that is changed in there except
that maybe the word the word who is not
there. That's all you're saying to me
right now. Kareem, notice what you said
at first. At first you said
that all the Qurans everywhere are the
same even in their wording. They're the
same, right? So I'm I'm showing you cuz
I agree with you. I agree with you that
even with this difference
the meaning of the verse doesn't change.
I
I'm sorry I'm sorry allow me to
interrupt.
For these things that you said the three
Quran that you presented that Yeah. that
is that is recitations. For the
This is something about the Arabs.
This is something about the Arabs. Back
at the time there were a lot of tribes,
you know? I need you to
different Arabic
speaks in different kind of dialects.
Can you hear me?
Can you hear me? Yes, yes. All right, I
need you to listen to me really quick,
okay?
Yeah. These aren't I'm not talking about
recitation, how you say a word.
I'm talking about the reading of the
text. The text here
has a word that is gone
uh in the other Qurans. But it's
just a word, yes, but it it's just a way
of uh speaking
Kareem, I need you to listen.
I understand
that even with the word gone in the
other Qurans
the meaning of the verse stays the same.
It doesn't change the meaning.
However, the wording of the text the
wording of the verse is different. Can
we agree with that?
Yes. Okay. So your point was earlier
wasn't that they have the same meanings
of all the Qurans you said that they're
word for word the same. So I'm showing
you that they're not word for word the
same.
Now if you want to say that the meaning
doesn't change, that's fine. I can give
you that in this case.
Now I can show you another case where
there's different with it's a different
word that does change the meaning. Can I
show you that?
Uh please go go ahead. Okay.
All right. So let me show you
where it changes the word and the
meaning.
So here's chapter 37
verse 12.
So this is the Hafs reading. This is
Qalun. Now they say the same thing,
Warsh. They say the same thing as as
each other.
All right. Can you read the verse for
us?
Uh bal ajibta wa yaskharun.
Awesome. And And what is the What is If
you could translate that in English,
what does ajibta mean? Ajibta. I don't
know.
Uh ajibta.
Uh it's like uh
can um
I don't know exactly, but it's surprise.
>> Like you were surprised, right?
Something like this. Right, good. So it
says, "But you were surprised while they
mocked." Right?
Yes.
All right. So Allah is speaking to
Muhammad
when he was reciting the Quran to the
disbelievers and they they mocked
Muhammad, they mocked the revelation.
Allah says to him, "But you ajibta, but
you were surprised while they mock."
Right? So this is the word we're going
to be paying attention to, ajibta. You
were surprised, okay?
Yes.
>> Now we're going to scroll down here
to another reading of the Quran.
See, usually there a lot of them say the
same thing, but there's others that say
that will have a difference. So here it
is. There's the difference. It does it
in colors, that's why I like this
website. It colors the difference.
I go go ahead and read this one. This is
the Khalaf Quran. Khalaf on the
authority of Hamzah. Yes, yes. Bal
ajibta wa yaskharun. Yes. It's so it's
like uh Mhm.
So same thing, right? It means surprise.
However, the subject changes, right? In
in earlier,
is you were surprised while they mocked.
is
I was surprised while they mocked,
correct?
Yes.
So, now it changes from So, Allah is
saying, "You, Muhammad, were surprised
while they mocked." to in this reading
of the Quran, Allah is saying, "I was
surprised while they mocked."
So, those are two completely different
things, right?
Yes, different. You know for who
different these things that you're
saying to me. You know different for
who?
Do you know who They're different in the
Quran.
For who? For who?
For which people?
For anyone. differences that you're
presenting. They are different from who?
From which which which one's
perspective?
Uh
from the Quran's perspective, brother.
No, it's from
>> on which Quran you're reading. If you're
reading this Quran, it's you were
surprised.
If you're reading this Quran, it's I was
Because these readings that you present
these readings it's even like it's even
written there. It's in the this reading
different readings. Yes.
>> for It's not for for for It's for
different people. You know what I mean?
For different people who reads that in
that way. You know what I mean? For the
Arab
tribes. I got you.
They were They were given these texts.
Because you have to understand
history of the Arabs to be able to
understand why is it like this different
from
there are some small
slightly changes or differences.
Yeah, but this isn't small, right?
Saying Allah saying, "I was surprised."
is not a small difference. Would you
agree?
It's not that difference. It's not Allah
is saying is It's the Quran is for It's
not for a specific group of people. For
different people that reads in different
ways.
You just try to understand what saying.
It's not for like it's not the same for
everyone. Some people reads in in
different ways, you know what I mean?
And then so and and let me listen to me.
And the text needs to be adjusted for
the way they speak. You have to
understand what I'm saying.
Oh, I I understand what you're saying.
Here's the problem though. The problem
is, Kareem, is that you made the
argument earlier that the Quran is
consistent all across the world. And
that wherever you go in the world, it's
the same and there's no change. There's
no difference. However, when we actually
look at these Qurans, there are
differences and it's not just in
wording, but in meaning as well. The
meaning changes. The context changes.
So,
it Now, here's the big problem. Just
listen to this. Remember, the the the
theology of Islam is that the Quran is
revealed by Allah. It's the speech of
Allah, right? Verbatim his speech. Mhm.
So, so this is the issue. It's which one
did Allah actually say? Did he say, "You
were surprised?" talking to Muhammad, or
did he say, "I was surprised." talking
about himself? Which one did he say?
Those two are completely different
things.
Yes.
You understand? So, the Qurans are not
the same.
But you can you know, let's
I'm I cannot like I'm not going to sit
here and like tell you that I know the
answer to the answer to these little
detail questions that I'm not educated
enough to for these things. Sure.
>> That's not say that the answer is not
there. It's just that it mean that I
don't know it. But what I'm saying to
you,
the foundation of my faith, of why I
believe what I believe,
it's not
I I I I can
defend it myself, you know what I mean?
I can explain it.
It's enough for me to believe what I
believe. These detail questions that I
don't know the answer to, I cannot like
base my faith on it on them. There is an
answer to that question, but I don't
know the answer to it. That's what I'm
saying to you. Let me let me tell you
something.
Yes.
>> Sorry.
Sorry, let me tell you why this is
important. It's it's directly relevant
to you, right? Remember I asked you,
what was it? What is it
that that convinced you that the Quran
is from God? And what you told me was
its consistency
and how it's
>> I haven't finished my answer. I haven't
finished my answer yet. I know, just
just in line with this particular thing.
You're saying it's consistency and the
fact that it's unchanged. Like you can
go anywhere in the world Yes, yes. and
the Quran is preserved word for word the
same with the same meaning. And that's
the opinion held by every every Muslim
on the planet will tell you this, but I
know. to explain the issue that you
presented to me, I I told you I haven't
I don't have the answer to it.
>> I know, that's fair.
>> you. I know. I know, that's fair. Let
let me just let me just explain.
>> There is this popular unchanged opinion
that the Quran is
I I got you. You know what I'm telling
you right now, Kareem, I know what
you're saying.
What I if I bring up any Muslim up here,
they'll say the same thing you're
saying. They'll say the same thing.
Exactly, sir. This is why I'm doing this
is why I do what I do. I'm doing what
I'm doing because a lot of Muslims, most
Muslims in the world are misled by this
myth
um that the Quran is perfectly preserved
word for word letter for letter the same
wherever you go. That's why I'm doing
this. It's to show you that the very
foundation of your belief, like what you
gave me. This is what you said. The the
foundation of your belief that it's
unchanged, the Quran's unchanged and
it's perfectly consistent wherever you
go. I'm showing you that that's not
true. The Quran every
when you look at different Qurans, it's
inconsistent. They're not the same.
Their meanings are changed.
So, the reason why you you to the Quran
and believe it's from God is what I'm
saying is the same reason that you
should reject it because that's not it's
not true.
But when you say different Quran, like
do you do you think that there's this
Quran, this Quran, this Quran, or do you
think that it's
it's just a copy that everyone has with
the same
With this Quran, this Quran, and this
Quran. These are all different Qurans,
my brother.
But it's not like it's they're not
labeled as different. They're different
readings. It's a recitation. Like you
said earlier I heard this I don't know
when where
reading of Warsh, reading of this,
reading of this. I'm not educated about
these things, but I believe there is an
answer to it and I I've heard it before,
but I don't know how to defend it right
now. So I'm sorry. If you want me to
carry on why I believe
this is uh
Yeah, yeah. Let's let's Give me another
Give me another reason.
>> No no reason. It's another reason. Give
me another reason why you believe it's
from God.
>> just one of them, you know what I mean?
Well, this this can't be one of them
now. This this one's on the shelf right
now. This one's way I can't defend it,
but there's an answer to it. That's all
I can say, you know?
>> There's not an answer, man. I've been
doing this a long time.
Well, I'm I'm I'm sure I've heard it
before, but you just got to
I just got to
find someone that can answer it for you,
but I can't. I'm sorry. Okay. If you
want me to carry on to a second reason
why I told you
All right. So yeah, so so what what is
something else that is that has
convinced you that the Quran is is from
God?
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. And this is
this is
uh you know what I mean? More than the
consistency part, you know? Okay. Uh
about the when I when I told you in the
beginning
uh people were saying that to me that
this is from God. Like who wrote this
book?
The author of the Quran is God. Well,
how was it it was revealed to a man
called Muhammad, you know? Peace be upon
him. That That's what we know. That's
what we know.
But
what is it about it? Like yes, it's just
a book consistent We can even add this.
It's consistent that change and this and
all of this.
But what is it about it?
How can we can we put two books the
Quran and another book and say this from
God this is from this is from God.
>> Well, it's not consistent. We already
got that part. But you know, I'm just
saying yeah, yeah, I told you
the fact that it's consistent and never
change even if we gave it this
which it is but you know We can't we
can't give it to you right now. Even
even if I told you even if we get give
it to it, it doesn't mean it's from God
like what is it about it
it's from Okay, so yeah, so what what
makes it from God brother? That's what I
need to
>> That's what I'm
that's what I'm that's what I'm getting
to.
What I found is
when I research why is it from God like
what is it about it? What's contained
that is from God? The informations that
they that are in the Quran the way the
Quran speaks
about things in the world about
scientific miracles, scientific
discovery that we're making today.
The way it speaks about the way it
speaks about them
in a very confident and strangely
accurate way and also highlight not
ambiguous not ambiguous way you know
what I mean that's the way that's more
important. Okay.
You can make a lot of
speak about a lot of things in a very
ambiguous way you know, you say things
and you you don't want to
you're afraid to make a mistake you know
what I mean? You're afraid to make a
mistake that's why you don't you cannot
fully speak about the topic like really.
>> I I mean miracles Quran is that what
you're saying scientific miracles? The
things yeah, the things that
are in the Quran All right, so let me
ask you a question right now. Let me ask
you this. So with with the standard that
you just gave me
so
because the Quran
very clearly makes scientific claims
that we're even just now discovering
that are true.
Just our truth.
>> that it lines up with science the Quran
lines up with science
is a is a is a demonstration
that the Quran is from God. Is that
correct? But this could never been this
could never come from a human, you know.
Got it. Okay. So, let me ask you
>> Especially if we read the context of
where the Quran was, you know. Let me
ask you this then.
Then this means that the opposite is
true. If the Quran gets things
scientifically incorrect,
then that would mean that it's not from
God and it's man-made, right?
Yes. Okay. So, let me show you
something, man.
Let me show you something. I'm going to
I'm going to show you
a scientific inaccuracy. So, it talks
about Dhul-Qarnain. I'll show the show
the screen.
Talks about Dhul-Qarnain. It says
Let's use one. So, he followed a way.
All right. So, he followed a way
until Oh, look at this. Oh, how how
awesome this is. How they lie. Let's
make sure we get one that doesn't try to
add in and be honest with the text.
There we go.
All right. So, he followed a way until
when he reached the setting place of the
sun.
He found it setting in a spring of black
muddy water.
And he found a people near it.
We said, "Oh, Dhul-Qarnain, either you
punish them or treat them with
kindness."
So, the Quran is saying that
Dhul-Qarnain found the place here on
earth where the sun sets and it sets
in a spring of
hot water.
Is that scientifically accurate?
What? What did you say? Is it
scientifically accurate that the sun
sets here on earth in a spring of water?
>> [laughter]
>> The the the the the phrasing the
phrasing of the word. He found it.
Mhm. He found it. Yeah. What Do you Do
you Do you think that it's literally
meaning he he he found it like he saw it
that he he he he found out where the sun
actually sets? Or he just he just
Yeah, cuz it cuz it says the same thing.
>> perspective, you know?
It says the same thing that he found the
people living there, too.
Because I Because the verse you present
I read it in Arabic, so I I literally
don't don't see the problem with the
verse before I know the Arabic version.
Good. It doesn't say like exactly He
found it like he he discovered it like
he You know what I mean? The way you you
want to present it, you know what I
mean? It doesn't mean the way you
present it.
It says he found it in Arabic.
Yes, he found it, but for Arabic for for
me as an Arabic speaking, he found it
doesn't mean the way you want to present
he found it like he actually like found
where the act the sun sets, you know?
It's more than that.
Look, it's not just that he found it. He
reached it.
He when he reached the setting place of
the sun,
he found it setting in a spring of hot
water.
So, he reached the place, he made it to
his destination, and and found it.
Like when when you go when you go to the
beach or something and sun is setting.
All right?
Yeah, we don't
Yeah, no one would ever say that. When
the sun is when the sun is setting,
did you reach the place where the
You can see the sun setting, you know
what I mean? No. No. That's what I'm
trying to say. Yeah, the answer is no.
Why? We can't reach where the sun sets.
That's impossible. No one would ever say
that.
But you know that the like the sun
setting or sun is
What's that? The the sun is setting and
sun is rising. Like the sun doesn't
actually rise and doesn't actually set.
It's just our perspective. It's the way
we see it. Yeah, but the Quran says
that. The Quran And not only does the
Quran say it, Muhammad says it. Are you
Sunni?
Yes, I am. Yeah, Muhammad clear Muhammad
elaborates on this and doubles down and
says, "Yes, the sun sets in water." Want
to see it?
In the Hadiths. Yes, yes, in the Hadith,
brother. Let me show you. Honestly, I
told you, the way I read it in my
Arabic, there is no problem, there is no
issues in in it's just in the
translation of me, the way you interpret
how you read the the verse. No, it's it
has nothing to do with interpretation.
We're we're taking the verse for what it
says. It says he reached the place where
the sun sets and he found it setting in
a spring of muddy water. So, it's not
>> it. It doesn't say that.
He found it. He found It's not he found
it, like I told you. Yes, it is.
>> it.
>> [laughter]
>> If you translate That's the thing, if
you if you translate the the meaning
might change for your language, you know
what I mean? Mhm. But it's the the the
real meaning, you don't have to you have
to to look for a translation that is
actual, actually, you know? Not word for
word, but meaning for meaning, you know?
Okay.
>> That's how you don't get it wrong, like
he found it, you think it's just he
found it literally
found it, you know what I mean?
Let me show you something. Let me show
you that Muhammad actually doubles down
on this. Sunan Abu Dawud 4002,
it's grade sahih, it's authentic.
Narrated Abu Dharr,
"I was setting behind I was sitting,
sorry, I was sitting behind the
messenger of Allah, who was riding a
donkey while the sun was setting."
He asked, "Do you know where this sets?"
Right? So, he's talking about literal.
"I replied, Allah and his apostle know
best."
"He said, 'It sets in a spring of warm
water.'"
So, this isn't about it appearing how it
appears to set or
uh
from his perspective, Muhammad is making
an absolute claim that the sun sets in a
spring of warm water.
You see what I'm saying?
I have never seen the this hadith, but
I don't know.
I don't know. I don't know. I don't
know. I don't know.
The It's okay.
What what is it about? I don't I don't
really know how to
>> It's a It's about the sun setting.
Brother, he's he's he's clarifying about
where the sun sets as you see. Abu Dharr
is sitting behind the behind the
messenger
while they're riding a donkey.
Right? And the sun is setting. It's
getting dark.
And so, Muhammad It's not Abu Dharr who
asked. Muhammad is the one who brings it
up. He says,
"Do you know where this sets?" Right? Do
you know where the sun sets?
Abu Dharr replies and says, "Allah and
his apostle know best. I don't know
where it sets."
And so, Muhammad responds and answers.
He says,
"It sets in a spring of warm water."
Just like how the what the Quran says.
So, this is a scientific inaccuracy. The
Quran got this wrong. Muhammad got this
wrong.
No. No. If we take for the Quran only,
not the
I don't know how to explain this hadith.
I don't know. I'm not going to Like I
said, when I don't know, I don't know.
I'm not going to
explain or tell you things that I don't
know. But for the Quran, like I said,
like I said and again and again.
The way I read it, like this source
Al-Kahf, we the chapter of Al-Kahf, we
read it every Friday in the mosque and
at home every every every week.
It's
There's nothing
in the way you presented
this to be an issue. There's no problem.
You know what I mean?
But since you you want to pick for the
the inaccuracies of the Quran,
what How about you talk about the real
miracles, the scientific proven miracles
that that are true, you know what I
mean? You're only taking the
this supposed inaccuracy. How do you
explain the others?
Let me ask you this. Actually proven.
Let me ask you this. If the Quran if the
Quran
got everything correct. If it had all
these things that were correct, but got
one thing wrong,
would it be from God?
There is the thing. You know what You
know what you do right now?
You You want to You want to hold on to
this
pro this thing that I cannot explain. I
like I said, I cannot explain right now.
You don't have
>> You want to hold on to it I just want
you to answer
>> mistake. You know what I mean? I just
want you to answer this. If it If the
Quran got one thing wrong, would it
would it be from God? No. Yeah,
[clears throat] no, it wouldn't be from
>> Right. So, that's
>> There's only one mistake that Right.
Exactly. So, this This is why I'm not
worried about the other things that I
can We can go over on another day and I
can show you why those things aren't
actually accurate to what you think they
are,
but I'm I'm able to grant you those
things. If I can show you just one wrong
thing,
then that means that the Quran is not
from God.
But you're you're you're not showing
something like like
like a
a break through mistake. Like something
that is You're not showing something
really clear. Like something that is I
think you're being
>> you know what I mean?
You're in denial.
>> Something that is
that is about perspective like I said
and I can't explain it because I
>> It's not about per Hold on. Let me do
this again. It's not about perspective.
Correct? It did Is Is Muhammad talking
about perspective or is he talking about
absolutes?
For the Hadith I I told you I I don't
I've never seen this Hadith. I don't I
don't know it.
>> I know, but you For the Quran I told you
the Quran part
I have no problem with it since I'm
Arabic reader. I know,
I know, but you are you're you're you
can think for yourself.
So, when you read this Hadith,
is Muhammad talking about a subjective
experience or is he speaking as a matter
of fact objectively that this is where
the sun sets?
Is he talking about an opinion, or is he
stating this as a fact?
I don't I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
You can't You can't read it and and and
answer this?
This question?
>> I so I can read it, but I can't I I I
don't know what what it's what it's
about to what what it I don't know. I
don't I'm not going to
So, this is what I'm This is what I'm
saying, brother. Kareem, look, listen.
Cuz I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I
but
a in the meantime you're you're not
being you're not allowing yourself to be
honest enough to say the truth when you
see a problem.
You know what I'm saying? And so, that's
that's my issue right now is that you're
not willing
>> The only problem here is I told you the
only problem here for this that you
presented is that I don't know. That's
the problem. You do know that. I don't
know.
>> know. That's the thing. I'm not uh
I told you I'm so not so deep educated
into the Hadiths and how to
explain this or whether this this is
reliable, this is not. I don't know.
Okay.
>> That's the only thing I can say. But, I
told you the other
I got you.
I have I have a lot of guests, but
listen, I go live every Monday,
Wednesday, and Friday, okay?
Please look look into this. I I want to
see what you learn when you look into
it, okay? And come back and we'll talk
about it, all right?
All right, thank you. All right, God
bless you, bro. I'm live same time
Monday, Wednesday, Friday every week,
okay? All right, thank you, bro. All
right, God bless you, man.